he's an American guitarist singer
songwriter and producer who sold over 15
million albums worldwide he started his
career as a music transcriptionist for
Frank Zappa he began a solo career in
1983 has released eight solo albums and
won three Grammy Awards he Steve Vai and
hear his top ten rules for success
the thing that you're most comfortable
with that you do the best because that's
what you're gonna do yes you know from
like me
I've got strengths and I've got
weaknesses I don't work on my weaknesses
I ignore them and I cultivate my
strengths the level of achievement that
we have at anything is a reflection of
how well we were able to focus on it
because the only thing that's holding
you back is the way you're thinking if
you're going to take any advice from me
I would tell you to find the thing that
excites you the most and go after that
whether it's just playing you know a Led
Zeppelin song and not practicing scales
and you don't have to know music you
know you tell Jeff Beck to play an F
sharp on the g string might not know
what it is well maybe you would know
that but you know but you know great
musicians don't necessarily have to know
about music the important thing is is to
find what it is that excites you and
disregard what anybody else is doing or
saying and just go after that that's
what you're going to be the most
successful at also it's good to have a
goal and wherever you set your goal you
have to have the patience the discipline
in the faith break it down and take it
step by step even if your goal is to be
able to play a Beatles song on the beach
that that's a particular goal and you
need to break it down and build and have
faith and have the
visualize yourself doing it you know and
if you visualize yourself doing it and
you stick to your your guns there's
nothing in the world that can stop you I
recommend that you pick a time that's
yours a time when you shut off the cell
phone shut off the telephone turn off
the internet and and sit and focus on
your goal and then I would learn I
wanted to understand music I always
loved the idea of knowing the language
of music you know to me music on paper
was like art it looked beautiful you
know I could never really you know
poetry was just words to me at the time
art was just paint mixed together you
know if I ever tried to draw something
it's like stick figures you know I got
no talent whatsoever but music was just
beautiful you know and it looked like
art and I wanted to know what it meant
and I wanted to be able to control it
and I wanted to be able to master it and
so I studied music not just the guitar
and I was composing before I was even
playing the guitar and whenever you
whenever you go to do something
creatively you're always well at least
me you know there's these little voices
of insecurity or whatever you know that
stop us from doing certain things you
know it's not good enough or you can't
do this or nobody's going to like it
you're going to be made fun of you know
this isn't what everybody else is doing
but when you get a good idea but when
you get a compelling idea it's almost
like a fever it transcends all of the
insecurities and you get this you know
profound desire to make it real it's no
work there's no working boy
because it's all the joy because you
know you're reaching your goal I'm
saying I never work a day in my life I
mean with
I never struggled honestly I've had a
lot of challenges I've had to you know
I've been through a lot but when it came
to my feelings about what I do and my
success so to speak never struggled a
day in my life
because for me playing the guitar was my
dues and whatever you really whatever
you really really really want you get
and whatever you really really really
don't want you get because whatever your
mind is focusing on you pull these
things into your life so your
perspective is so important and for me
it was a slow slow slow slow build but I
got me out of that depression and really
lifted me up and I mean and every and I
don't lose you know and sometimes you go
like this you know it's not just a
straight you know and but but I've I've
always kept that desire you know what I
mean and it's a sincere desire and when
you ask for something like that you
start seeing things about yourself
because really the way the world is
relative it's the way you see yourself
that shapes the world you know doesn't
shape the world it shapes your
perspective on the world so if you want
to continually change you have to have
that desire you know so you know I can
pinpoint certain things in my certain
points in my life where you know you
have these moments of clarity you know
like I was talking about the academic
portion the clarity of the guitar but
there's really these we all have these
very subtle intuitive moments of clarity
but you have to want them if you're
stuck in a particular way of thinking
for your whole life you're not going to
get them you have to see them you have
to want to be you want to how you want
to you have to want to improve yourself
as a person you can see
all day and practice for years but when
you get on a stage and the lights are on
everything changes okay nothing feels
the same as the garage your foot pedals
your sound everything is different even
if you've done a sound check because
people come in the room and it makes
everything sound different and it's easy
to be like a deer in the headlights know
what that was
we're making one of my play okay you
lose your note when that happens what
I've learned to do mostly design is just
make-believe
everything sounds great just
everything's good I know that relax and
breathe and that helps so much really
because the thing that's making you know
you're freaked out is just not feeling
comfortable because maybe there's people
watching or the lights lights change
everything you can I cannot receive you
guys I can't really see my pedals very
well and that can freak you out if
you're not used to it you know so if you
kind of learn to go in almost on
autopilot and zone out and zone him and
the best way to get there is relaxing
and just then when I say relaxed you
think about it be great your attention
into relaxing
and reading and then you go about
pushing in to do great you've good
grounds your rings back never you get
discouraged go to the big picture go
back to that place of excitement that's
how you get to it you go to the big
picture you go to the chief aim because
it's so crystallized in your head that
when you know when you feel like I can't
do this you know you go back to that
picture and you can see yourself doing
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Aaron Gonzales asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rules meant the most to you leave it
in the comments I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching to believe and I'll see you
soon